cuáles son las siguientes ecuaciones son
equivalentes a la siguiente ecuación una
letra mayúscula representa a una matriz
y una letra minúscula representa a un
escalar supón que todas las matrices son
cuadradas bien lo primero la ecuación de
aquí nos dice que la matriz b por la
matriz a es igual a la matriz de
entonces pensemos cuáles de éstas son
equivalentes para todas las matrices
cuadradas b ya aquí cambiaron el orden
ahora es a por de y hemos visto en
múltiples ocasiones que la
multiplicación de matrices no es
conmutativa no siempre es el caso en el
que ve por a es igual aa por b entonces
podemos descartar ésta
en esta mantienen el orden tiene ave por
am
por a pero introdujeron un escalar están
multiplicando el escalar por b y eso por
a y de hecho lo podemos hacer en un
orden diferente y eso después lo vamos a
ver pero sólo para mostrarles que esto
es lo mismo que de hagamos un ejemplo
hagámoslo con matrices de dos por dos
hagámoslo aquí y claro esto no es para
comprobar si no solamente para mostrar
el caso de una matriz de dos por dos
pero con suerte y les da un poco de
seguridad
entonces
tenemos
de una
de tus
de 3 y
y vi 4
esta es
ah
sabemos el resultado de esta
multiplicación sabemos cuánto valdrá de
sera
era
igual
de uno a uno de uno de uno
a uno más de dos a tres más de dos a
tres y sabemos que el siguiente término
será de 1 a 2
2 más de 2 a 4 de 2 a 4 y ahora
y ahora este término será de 3 a 1
a uno más de cuatro a tres
más de 4 a 3 y finalmente el último
término segunda fila segunda columna de
dos más de cuatro a cuatro de cuatro
a 4 y entonces ese es el resultado de la
multiplicación veamos qué sucede si
introducimos una r si introducimos una r
aquí entonces multiplicar b por r es
igual a tomar a la r y multiplicarla por
cada uno de estos términos y si hacemos
eso eso es igual a poner una erre en
cada lugar donde veamos un ave solo lo
multiplicamos por una r ahí va una r ahí
va una r va una r ahí ahí va una r
ahí va una r ahí va una r y ahí va una r
y claramente esto va a ser lo mismo que
erre multiplicada por la matriz de
nuestra matriz de es la que sería si en
las erres pero si la multiplicamos por
la r obtendremos esta cosa que está aquí
ojalá esto les haga sentir bastante bien
que este argumento de aquí y es cierto
por aquí el siguiente también tiene a b
por a pero ahora están multiplicando r
por a y por exactamente la misma razón
por la misma razón
déjenme me regreso aquí y vuelvo a
palomear la que ya había palomeado
sabemos que esta es verdad
ahora por exactamente la misma razón
sabemos que si multiplicamos a por r
tendremos r r r r
entonces para cada lugar donde veas una
app
habrá una r en frente entonces eres en
todos en todos estos lugares
entonces por exactamente la misma razón
por exactamente la misma razón el
escalar multiplicado después de la y del
pse cuenta no estamos cambiando el orden
de la multiplicación de matrices sigue
siendo b por a pero el escalar puede
estar antes del ave o después de la a o
podemos multiplicar el escalar por a y
hacer b por esa a r entonces esa es
esa es equivalente
ahora aquí están tomando el reporte por
ve fundamentalmente están cambiando el
orden de la multiplicación de matrices
la multiplicación de matrices no es
conmutativa entonces podemos decir
podemos decir que ésta está afuera ahora
está esta interesante r por b por r por
entonces pensemos en esto
esta es de esta esa y esta es de ahora
pensemos en lo que pasará si ponemos r
por b
veremos seres en todas ellas
r por am
veremos eres por allí
y por ejemplo este término de aquí será
r por b 1 por r por 1 entonces eso será
r cuadrada por de 1 a 1
y me disculpo porque se está viendo un
poco revuelto por aquí el segundo
término de aquí será rp 2 por r3 y este
será r cuadrada de 2 a 3 y si seguimos
vamos a poner erre cuadrada en frente de
cada uno entonces ésta será lo mismo que
multiplicar el escalar erre cuadrada por
la matriz de por lo que ésta también es
equivalente